he's the popular peter king
nbcsports.com nfl columnist
football morning in america back from a
lengthy vacation
and ready to dive into all the topics
here today
good morning pete um how confident are
you this season is going to start on
time
i think the season is likely to start on
time dan the question is
uh will it finish and uh
will it play without being interrupted
and you know i think one of the biggest
issues the nfl faces
is even though they're going to lead the
world
in contact tracing then i had a tour of
the minnesota vikings
facility on uh friday
and it was totally fascinating i could
tell you 40 stories but one of them i
thought was really interesting
after you take your covet test after you
get your temperature
taken after you fill out your form on
your
your phone that says you are not uh
you're not warm you haven't been out of
the country or anything like that
you are going to be given basically a
little fob
and that fob is gonna you're gonna wear
all day you wear it on your wrist you
can wear it in your pads you can put it
in your pocket
and that little fob is basically going
to be
the physical distancing measuring device
that anybody else you come in contact
with that day who also is going to have
a fob
they're going to know hey you're within
two feet of kirk cousins now so if you
do test
positive uh then you know
they know that they have to also check
out kirk cousins to make sure he doesn't
have it
but the big question is so what happens
if you go through a day there's not
going to be instant testing then
what happens if you go through a day and
you go through a practice
and you know you have your hands on your
center you have your hands on defensive
guys
you're in a huddle you're around a lot
of players
so what's the nfl going to do then that
is going to be
a huge issue as to whether the season
can be played in its entirety and in
some week when
whether you know some team doesn't get
six positive tests on the offensive line
what you were talking about is that just
a viking only
procedure or no all 32 teams
are going to this is going to be uniform
with all 32 teams
every one of the excuse me every one of
the players on the team
and every one of 100 team
officials who are going to be in contact
like coaching staff
trainers equipment people the gm
every one of those 100 people who can be
in contact with the players
you know they're all going to wear these
fobs
uh during the day so they'll have them
on them at all times
you had a orchestrated player's twitter
attack yesterday on the nfl with their
safety guidelines but
judging from what you're telling me i
mean these are pretty
good safety precautions advanced safety
precautions
what are the players complaining the
most about here
well i think there's a couple of things
the players richard sherman told me
stridently over the weekend
that they want to have daily testing and
dan it's a very simple reason at first i
said
daily testing man that's that's too much
here
is the issue with not testing daily
you're not going to get instant results
with your tests so let's say that you're
tested three times a week
you're tested monday wednesday
saturday and i you could pick any days
okay but let's say you're tested three
times a week
and let's say on on wednesday you test
okay you're gonna go through your day
most likely without having any idea
whether you've tested positive or
negative
so now you know you might get the
results back
on thursday okay but you've already had
that period on wednesday where you're
around your team
and now because thursday and friday
there's no testing
how do your teammates people who've been
around you maybe been in the huddle with
you
they're not getting tested till saturday
i mean if nine of them test positive on
saturday you might not have a game on
sunday
so i think players definitively want to
have
testing daily uh and
and i don't know if the nfl is going to
agree to that i think
that they might agree to it for a period
of time but i don't know if they're
going to agree to it for a full
season he's peter king and his column is
football morning
in america released earlier today is the
nfl planning on having fans
i think if they can dan but uh i think
it'd be foolish now to think you can
have fans in a place like tampa or miami
or
or arizona uh you know i think it's
going to be a case-by-case basis
um and i do think that
some teams at some point this year are
going to admit
fans socially distanced and
you know having the stadium experience
being totally different not being
allowed to tailgate things like that
but yeah at some point this year i do
think some
teams will allow a percentage of their
stadium to take on phoenix so you think
this will be almost like state by state
with governors this is going to be team
by team that the commissioner is going
to let
you decide if you're going to have
probably okay i think probably because
look it it seems
kind of totally unfair let's just say
that
if in the state of wisconsin you're
doing great
on testing and uh you've gone
you know 17 days without without a death
due to coronavirus in wisconsin uh and
your schools are open and everything why
do the packers have to play with no fans
there
just because there's a big outbreak in
houston
yeah the packers can't play with fans
dan i wrote this
a few months ago i said everybody who's
connected
in any way with the nfl needs to get
ready for a season of
inconvenience and quite frankly
unfairness
okay now you know if a situation like
with the blue jays happened
where a team couldn't play at home the
nfl is not canceling the sea baseball's
not cancelling the season
they're telling the blue jays find a
place to play
so maybe they'll play in buffalo maybe
they'll play in dunedin maybe they'll
play in some other team stadium
i don't know the point to make is that
this these are unusual times and i don't
think you can have a one-size-fits-all
rule
on things like fans i think it's just a
coincidence but i'm a little suspicious
that you went on vacation and didn't
have to deal with the dak prescott
contract negotiations
thank god the most talked about nfl
story
in decades here and here we are with
uh a franchise tag and we always want to
look at who won and who lost
you know and i i don't know what to
think anymore about this situation here
does jerry like dak but not love dak
you know did dak over play his hand so
now that you have come back
to join us here um what do you take away
from this doc prescott situation in
dallas
the cowboys blew it the cowboy should
have signed
dak prescott to a long-term contract
uh a year and a half ago and dan
i want you to look at the history of
quarterback negotiations
when has the price for a quarterback
ever gone down
the dallas cowboys blew a chance to get
dak prescott
at his cheapest you know last
offseason and they're going to pay the
price for it now
the real big question i didn't write
about this today because i only had 13
000 words
um but you know the real big question to
me about the dak prescott thing is what
happens next year
if the salary cap if the nfl forces all
the teams in the league
to take their medicine on the cap next
year and the cap goes down to 125
let's say the cowboys might have to just
say we got to cut bait with deck we got
to feel the team
we can't cut 15 players who are all
making
significant money so they might have to
get rid of them after this year now i
don't think they will
but this is why and i said it at the
time
and i've read everybody saying oh my god
don't sign a 12-year contract or
or whatever but to me patrick mahomes
there was a little bit of tom brady in
what patrick mahomes did
in that he gave the kansas city chiefs
the advantage of the next two years
keeping the core intact by having a five
million dollar cap number this year in a
24 million or whatever it is next year
what he has done
rather than be the pig at the trough you
know and take a huge
amount of money this year next year
early on in the contract
he'll get paid in a big way later
the kansas city chiefs are not cutting
patrick mahomes
and so basically the chiefs i think did
a very smart thing
for the first seven years of his
contract it averages about 36 million
dollars and you say oh my god that's a
lot of money
no it isn't it's very reasonable for the
best player in football
and that's a good contract for patrick
mahomes in my opinion
and a good contract for the chiefs any
response
from the nfl in the washington post
story
um well you know the nfl basically
uh is going to let the investigation by
the washington law firm take place and
then react to it
uh dan you know dan snyder's gotta go
period there is no uh there's no way he
should be an nfl owner but how does that
happen though peter it's not going to
happen i'm saying
i'm saying i'm in my opinion dan
snyder's got to go
he has to go and you know that wasn't
two or three instances
of sexual harassment that was 17
and you know that plus you know how
about
you know this is a i this really
gold me okay i wrote about it today how
about
in his release in the in the
organization's release when they say
we're gonna look into uh you know the
the uh the team nickname we're gonna
look into it
so the only word in that release
that was used more than the word the
was redskins yeah and that is a guy
who's saying
uh okay i know i gotta change the name
but up yours
i mean you know it's just it's time for
him to go he's gotta go
but also peter it hasn't done a donald
sterling thing
so he probably won't go but if you go
back to that memo
he he started with sponsors
like he he wanted to reach out to the
sponsors
community and fans like in that order
so you know that this was all this was
was about the bottom line with money
i'm losing sponsors don't want to lose
them
you know the heck with the community and
the fans nike and fedex
forced dan snyder to
transfer to the right side of history
and i can i mean i would bet you you
give him
sodium pentothal right now and you ask
him
do you want to change the name he
doesn't want to change the name
no come on yeah and and so i mean he
just
you know dan snyder is a bad owner
who unfortunately you know i remember as
i wrote today i remember when this team
was relevant
and this team was fun and rfk
stadium rocked and shook uh
when they had a competent ownership and
management team
jack kent cook was a weird guy but
he was a competent owner and now they
don't have one
and and if you don't have a competent
owner in the nfl
you are in trouble and that's why my i'm
serious
i mean i'm exaggerating my heart goes
out to covet patients
but my heart sort of goes out to
washington fans too
because their owner stinks
how can the nfl get him out of there
does does
any who has the power to say to dan
schneider you must don't
i mean i don't i don't see how how do
you get him out
uh you know he's he he has the ability
to stay as the owner of this team
uh unless he does something either
illegal
or or whatever now maybe
the investigation of his organization is
gonna find other wrongdoing
i don't know you had adam silver who
got rid of donald sterling well he got
rid of donald sterling but
you know it is donald sterling
has daniel snyder done a donald sterling
he was at the helm of a place
that had 17 cases of accused sexual
harassment inside his organization
okay so the question is is that enough
to uh rest control of a franchise well
jerry richardson with the panthers is
that
similar well with the panthers
uh you know it is similar for sure
but you know daniel snyder didn't do
personally
what jerry richardson did that's the
issue
good to talk to you pete glad you're
back ready to go
thanks a lot dan really appreciate it
that's peter king nbcsports.com
football morning in america